uh jordan what is going on
with uh assassin's creed infinity what
is this wait assassin's creed what
no no no no no no
you know the vibes all right continue
jordan back to back these non-stops
let's go knows what the [ __ ] is
happening with assassin's creed right
now
but uh right before ubisoft made the
official announcement
uh jason schreier came out with a report
being like hey
yubi's going in changing direction with
assassin's creed again they've gone from
open world adventure to rpg and now
they're going from rpg to
live service something
and uh it's gonna be take place on the
same platform but like just multiple
settings it's just gonna evolve like
taking inspiration from games like
fortnite
and uh grand theft auto online uh
and then ubisoft like i want to say like
an hour and a half
after that it was pretty quick release
the
official announcements like yeah we are
actually
doing that it's going to be a cross
studio thing between
uh montreal and quebec we still have the
super
problematic uh men in high positions
still in those high positions
working on this but we're hoping that
you overlook that and get excited at the
possibility of assassin's creed becoming
so
stupidly large that it just last thing
ever
oh my god this is so stupid
the thing is like i i said i said
something similar on twitter where i was
like i was hoping they'd get smaller
because i'm very much in the same
camp as many of you are especially
jordan like i want
smaller tighter more detailed more
controlled narrative tales and they are
going the opposite direction
and i had a few people like kind of
replying some people being
twitter people being like shut up no one
cares what you think um but other people
being like uh you know they they kind of
pointed out that you know they have
they're kind of mentioning that they
have the capacity to make those smaller
tails within this larger framework
yeah and that i i really want to get
behind the idea of that the problem that
i
foresee or the one that i can't get past
is
modern game design requires you to
to requires developers to like author
and construct these pathways
that take you to every corner of this
massive world otherwise it's pointless
having a massive world
and the way they do that is they create
these bread crumbs that are constantly
moving you from one thing to the other
and pulling you in multiple different
directions so that it never feels like
you're done
that's how these games as a service
games work right you never feel like i'm
done
this is it i've got a short tail i
experienced a complete narrative
it's always something there's always
something happening and so that's my
main worry about it sure they might be
able to tell these
tales smaller tales but will they be
able to resist the temptation of always
funneling you into another thing or
wasting your time
with me in your tasks that ultimately
have no bearing on what you're actually
doing from an area of perspective
that's my main worry i have two minds of
this
i'm i have no basis for my
beliefs theories as to what ubisoft is
as to what ubisoft is going to do from
like either
a they do something like what they were
teasing at the beginning of assassin's
creed unity where you like logged in and
you saw like a bunch of different
experiences to click from and it's like
oh this is a portal you boot up
assassin's creed
infinity and it like it starts with like
one
default uh campaign or maybe it's free
to play and then like each campaign is
like
twenty dollars here for like this
experience and maybe forty dollars here
for this much longer one and
etc etc etc or if they are
leaning more in towards what something
like
fortnite what grand theft auto online
does
it's a giant like open world
modern day assassin's creed where
occasionally over time the world is
evolving and at the same time
you have like an animus you can visit
that
uh you can use to do a bunch of single
player content in the past but like in
the present day it's like this open
world multiplayer experience where you
can participate in different activities
other people like
bring back the multiplayer from
brotherhood and three
okay bring back the siege things from
unity
stuff like that and i'm like i could see
it going either way i could see it doing
something completely
different the brotherhood multiplayer
i feel like i feel like that's exactly
what they have to do because they talk
about how it's going to have multiple
settings
and there's no cohesive way to make that
work in a
a kind of like seamless open world right
like you have to
i feel like it's going to be very much
that that case of like
the the main world is you know an
upstair goal like facility in a modern
day where you are a bunch of subjects
just and then you can pick and it's kind
of like
you drop in with all your friends and be
like all right let's go to
i don't know italy and then you all jump
into the animus together and it'll take
you all to
i don't know ac brotherhood's
multiplayer mode or a a
a curated experience that is a unique
assassin's creed 2 setting or
you know black flag setting etc etc i i
would struggle to see how they make a
a a larger um
experience that has multiple settings
cohesive outside of
hey there's a portal here jump through
it assassins and then you come out on
the other side and it's like oh you're
in another part of the world now
howard's will refuse to make a single
player game starring a woman
in assassin's creed they just won't do
it i just
won't do it uh something
i found interesting about the ubisoft
statement specifically is that
they when they were talking about it
they were talking about it less from the
perspective of
like what the game is going to play like
as a consumer and more about what that
means
from like actually developing it uh
specifically they were saying how like
they had this like new cross studio
collaboration structure
and like they said like i'm gonna read
what they said here uh quote
rather than continuing to pass baton
from game to game we profoundly believe
this is an opportunity for one of
ubisoft's most beloved franchises to
evolve in a more integrated
and collaborative manner that's less
centered on studios and more focused
on talent and leadership no matter where
they are
within ubisoft so it kind of sounds like
this is almost like a back end thing of
like
we can build this system that allows it
to
be easier for different teams of ubisoft
across the world to like
build their own assassin's creed game or
story
and like have it easily be integrated
rather than like
having like you know a bunch of
different teams like building multiple
assassin's creed games at the time and
they got it kind of it sounds like what
activision's doing with call of duty
exactly like few years ran into that
problem where you had like
you know infinite warfare and black ops
and they tried to fuse them together and
it like totally didn't work because
those are games were built on like
different engines and was kind of a mess
and i think ubisoft's like
we can avoid that by like building this
system from the grout up to support this
yeah like if you think about how a lot
of when ubisoft
where with assassin's creed how it gets
like handed off from studio studios like
a lot of stop and go stop and go
in terms like this studio is going to
make odyssey this studio is going to
make origins obviously they have they
have had collaboration when i
was like talking to developers about
odyssey they're like yeah this has been
long development because we work
alongside the origins team
uh to make sure that these games are
like
congruous they're not like just like
these completely separate experiences
that don't make sense
when you connect them together so i
think this is more of like a
framework for them to kind of
communicate how they're approaching sas
and screen
but if it's if it feels more continuous
i also think that
i mean i can't speak for y'all but
assassin's creed
based games are long as [ __ ] and i never
almost finished them right
now but they come but they come out but
they come out with a really good dlc
or they they have like the
their dlcs are chunky and are like
oftentimes
yeah they're like whole other games but
like no one like i imagine that
fewer people play those because they're
like yo i'm i'm done with this like i'm
not like what is this dlc i'm gonna buy
it for a game that i already bought
uh because now the mentality is the
expectation is to have
like if dlc is part of is packaged with
a game that you already bought or
something or it's an update
to something that you subscribe to uh or
something something like that and so i
think that this
this framing will help those at the
add-on content to kind of like string
you along
to the next assassin's creed game like
fate of atlantis like what what was that
like oh that was actually pretty fire
uh i don't know i didn't i didn't get to
it but if it like
yeah and then so but like i didn't touch
it but if i boot up a screen like oh
snap like
this i don't know i feel like it's just
a lot more seamless for
as a player and i imagine this can also
help them
be a lot more um i think more efficient
when it comes to like
making these games you know i think
there's a lot
i think i i wish they would sit down and
really unpack
the the knock-on effect of having the
games be
this large because for me i think one of
the biggest issues i have is like
because they're this large i do not
forget about the main characters
i'm incapable of caring about those
characters because one
the idea of playing a 70 hour game where
a significant portion of that game is
you
running boring errands and doing like
random side [ __ ]
it just it doesn't endear me to a
character it makes
every every character in assassin's
creed
modern assassin's creed even like um
bayek is like
you aren't really an assassin you're an
errand you know
you're an errand boy aaron girl you're a
yeah he's i mean
a bike wasn't exactly a cop but like
even like cassandra like cassandra i was
like
i want to care about you but you keep
running off and doing this
boring [ __ ] for a really long time and i
just cannot
like the last character in assassin's
creed that i really cared about was
probably
i don't know edward kenway like yeah i
was into him
but like i don't like jacob and evie and
syndicate
no not really because there was two of
them and i like i didn't really like the
back and forth between them like i want
to go back and give syndicate another go
honestly i kind of bounced off of them i
found them quite annoying
um but i think i was in a very irritated
phase of my life as well there where i
was just annoyed by everything
um but like i i wish i could care about
a character the way that i did care
about like altair and
and and uh or even like
the uh modern day stuff like i don't
know what the heck was going on with all
that and it's like
it's the same problem where it's even
more so because you're like okay you
introduced the modern character and then
you played 40 hours of odyssey and then
you cut back to the main character and
i'm like oh you remember their name
or what they were doing or what's going
on like so if they could like
is it couch
layla hassan yeah
yeah interesting good thing about
valhalla is the fact despite its
campaign being like
70 hours and to get like the true ending
you have to spend like another
20 on top of that for like a 90 100 hour
experience
is the fact that it like references
every single mainline game that came
before it and it just
wraps up all of those story lines so
altair
uh ezio connor edward arno
jacob evie just all of bayek uh
cassandra
and basically it's like all right put a
lid on it it's done we've wrapped
everything up we even touch on desmond a
little bit
and we kind of complete that we are now
basically at
fresh slate we can go somewhere new
from a little excited then yeah that is
exciting but like
that exciting is immediately dulled by
knowing that
the next step isn't a isn't a
like really smart reset where they
curate
and finally craft a new character and
world it's this
platform that they've created where
anyone can be an assassin and you can go
anywhere and do anything it's like no
i was hoping you'd use this opportunity
to be like yo we've got an assassin's
creed too
like we've got we've got to come up with
a brand new assassin we've focused it
down
you're going to love this character it's
going to be really cool it's not it's
not that like
they're like all right we're making
fortnite or we're making gta online i'm
like i don't really care about that i
don't yeah yeah i want i want
to yeah jason schreier's report and
the official ubisoft uh press release
doesn't mention this but
trier's report mentions that like the
soonest we're getting this game is
2024 so three years
from now and so there's a possibility
that we get some sort of assassin's
creed experience between now
and this i'm keeping like fingers
crossed for a super like modern day
remake of assassin's creed one
but like it'll be interesting to see
like dude do we get
any assassin's creed between now and
infinity or is infinity just like what
happens after fall hall and we just take
a break from assassin's creed for like
three or four years
there's also no guarantee that this
infinity project actually
makes it to release like they were
they've been very upfront in that
they're talking about it like this is
something we're experimenting with and
we're figuring out
whether it happens or not isn't a dead
certainty they might get you know
a ways into development and think this
is not working and then we get something
else instead
it seems like the plan is to work on
that while working on um
valhalla dlc and maybe if we're lucky
we'll get a
another game in between i don't know
like i would love to see
one remake come on i'm in the same style
of re2 and re3 remake like just
completely
like up and running bring back
everything
bring back i mean like they did a bit of
that with revelations right where you
could go
back and play some of the altair stuff
but like i want them to make the
assassins creed they sold us
in the original assassin's creed trailer
from e3
like the the that trailer still is one
of the best
yeah and that game that the game that
came out absolutely
did not make it good on anything that
happens and
i think the technology was there yet
it's there now you can make it make your
assassin's creed one hitman game and
let's go
god that'd be so cool modern
mod uh it turns out that the next
assassin's creed is a
a modern almost futuristic uh
game and it stars a new assassin named
uh
samuel fisher yeah that's where we go
and it's a i want to sell game yeah i
would yeah
i mean like i would love that i have
been thinking a lot about spending so
like
i want um if you if you want more
explain a cell chat go to
the uh nuclear freedom assassin's creed
splinter cell game so that would just be
no
no no no no no no no it's kind of
relaxed similar
the same mechanics
so yeah we're definitely not getting an
actual
splinter cell for a while probably if
ever
rip but you know it's going to come in
as a live service game
all their franchises i was thinking
about this earlier like i
and there is a way to make a splinter
stall live service game that works
but i was thinking about this earlier
but i really missed like triple a or
even double a stealth games there's none
of them around right now that i
care about like there's no metal gear
there's no
splinter cell there's no thief there's
no
you know dishonored how was that game it
was by like
x uh hitman devs rob hanlery like loved
it
uh echo echo echo i feel like echo was
like the last game that
that game's very different obviously but
it was last game that was like trying to
be like
i'm sure there's an indie stealth game
that i can think of
yeah but like on the like i know there
are a bunch of indie stealth games but
like
very few of them have like a charismatic
central character
you know the way that we have like snake
or sam
or emily or corvo you know that kind of
that's what i yearn for another one of
those
and like okay together games industry it
was a good stealth game again
anyway let's let's move on to listen to
questions